this episode of the minimalist is
brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
non-minimalists
hello everybody welcome to the middles
podcast where we discuss what it means
to live a meaningful life with less my
name is joshua fields milburn and i'm
ryan nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists
and our culture more seems to be the
answer to everything ryan
more stuff more money more status more
friends more food more
sex more imbibing more pleasure more
more more the cult of more has become so
common
that we rarely stop to consider how much
is enough yeah let's change that today
ryan okay
today well we're going to talk about
enough ism
and we're going to identify how much is
enough
ryan has a secret number of things we'll
share on the private podcast that's
right stay tuned
for the perfect amount of things when
they were saying the meaning of life is
42 they meant 42 items right
exactly and then you'll find meaning
all the great mystics already knew this
wouldn't it be great if it was
that easy yeah and you know i don't know
if we need to wait till later in the
podcast to talk about this but
when it comes to enough we were talking
before we started recording i was trying
to
exclaim explain to you how i
look at enough like i look at perfection
okay it's like
there is only something can be only so
perfect
i'm agreeing with you 100 so far i also
look at enough
like i look at perfection yes yeah then
that's actually that's all it is
okay yeah although where did you not
agree
well i think that what i agree
what i disagree about maybe not even
disagree is
my understanding of enough is it is
birthed out of
subtraction almost always and so when
we're talking about enough ism today and
we're talking about
how to identify enough it's not about
how do i get more to get enough and
that's the problem with our culture
right it's about how do i subtract to
uncover
enough yeah i guess oh it's interesting
because i take it from the perspective
of
let's say there's someone who uh
is like has nothing
a homeless person okay so they start
from nothing
so then they start to bring things into
their lot like they need a home
right maybe they need a kitchen table so
that's where i'm taking it from so and
and that aspect of bringing in more if
you have nothing but you're right
most of us anyone listening already have
enough or too much
has enough or more than enough yeah
totally almost certainly
more than enough now because of nuance
ryan i think that
enough ism might be a even better
description
for minimalism in some respects yeah i
do want to differentiate the two real
quickly though
i think enough ism is actually one
step sort of more aesthetic than
than minimalism in a way because
minimalism also embraces
the non-essential items you and i as
minimalist it's not that we deprive
ourselves what we do is we identify what
is essential i.e
what is enough and then also we identify
what is
non-essential what's junk as minimalist
we we remove all the junk
from our lives this is called the no
junk rule in our minimalist rule book
16 rules for living with less you can
download that for free over on our
website
but with this new no junk rule what we
say is everything you own
can fit in one of three piles it's
either essential non-essential or junk
once we identify the junk we get rid of
that
i think there's two types of enough in
this scenario
when we think of enough we often think
of like the essential items
housing clothing
food or you know uh um
education transportation vocation
that's what we think of as essential but
then there's like all of the
non-essential many
of those are actual things in our life
and
if we're being a hundred percent candid
i have this glass here i'll hold it up
for the cameras this glass of water
yeah the water is enough right the glass
is value-adding but i could drink this
water
without tap i'll just well i wouldn't
drink tap water
uh yeah there's fluoride no other things
i don't want in my body
the water filter yes yeah yeah i i could
drink
water out of you know my hands or
whatever it might be
and so you're right i could drink water
out of the tap it'd be fine
but um when i actually might not be fine
there's also uranium and a lot of water
supplies now so
we're all living in some variation of
flint it's
unbelievable um any anyhow
when we get back to this the water is
essential the glass is non-essential but
it's value adding
yes and so that's a different kind of
enough one is enough as
i need something i need enough but then
there's the other sort of i desire
enough the
i desire the things that enhance or
augment
amplify my experience of life my couch
my kitchen table
my bed for many thousands of years
humans live without beds
yeah and therefore it can't be essential
right and yet in society
a bed is pretty much essential even even
we see homeless people who have beds so
when we talk essential
you're meaning like cert like able to
survive
like to live a to live a uh
healthy quality of life or a basic
standard of life no i think that's what
i'm talking about non-essentials to a
great extent
now often people will say non-essentials
and they lump junk into that and so i
want to be really clear i'm not talking
about junk
we spend 1.2 trillion dollars a year on
quote non-essentials but it's really
almost all junk
you know we're spending more on watches
and and jewelry than we are in higher
education
yeah and so there there is there
is a a way to look at our things whereas
if you take away all the things you look
at humanity
human humans have thrived for tens of
thousands
of years even without all of the modern
accoutrements right 100
so you're saying that those people tens
of thousands of years ago they had
enough that would be enough
they certainly had enough okay and and
they also didn't live in society and so
living in society you know
post-civilized world
we actually require some more
non-essentials
to get us to enough as well gotcha
so i'm saying that modern life does
require more than pre-civilized life and
i'm not
suggesting that you and i go back to
live in the woods with loincloths
as an experiment even that might be
non-essential the loincloth itself
right we're going commando before we get
into our questions ryan i wanted to
bring
this up to you you know we have
minimalist.org it's our 100 free local
meetup groups 100 different cities and
eight countries we also have an online
city if
none of the cities are near you or if
you just want to participate with
over 14 000 people in this group
and uh kathleen shared this i'll hold it
up for youtube if you're watching this
on youtube she has a version of enough
that's different for for her than it is
for me and i think it's one of the
things i want to get across here
when we're identifying what is enough in
terms of non-essentials your enough is
going to look different from my and
that's right
yeah so it's not universal enough yeah
and what's interesting about enough
uh-huh it's always changing yes it's not
this
it's not this uh this episode isn't
going to make someone realize like oh
here's what enough is
and then they're going to either go get
enough or they're going to get rid of
until they have enough
and then they're going to be like oh
okay i'm all finished
right never have to do that again and if
you're listening to this
right you can't go get enough right
enough
is not purchasable right enough is not a
product
enough is not a consumer good
right now you're right if we're living
in a state of deprivation if we're
starving to death then of course we
don't have enough
yeah i was thinking about like um toilet
paper for example
right so let's say someone right now
listening to this is out of toilet paper
they got to go get tp right
they don't want to buy it one square at
a time and they also don't want to buy a
pallet of toilet paper
right like there is a there is a uh well
i should say there isn't a number that
says enough but
you can get enough toilet paper uh
without having a specific number
there's an essence there right where if
i go by like i know if i go buy
a pack of toilet paper that has four in
it that's probably not enough for me and
my family
for a prolonged period of time and i
don't want to go to the corner store
every
other day to buy toilet paper and so i'm
going to buy enough for a
specific period of time yeah now it's
true that we could go through a pallet
of toilet paper
sure especially ella oh my gosh i don't
know what she's doing in that
wiper she's just wrapping around her
hands coming out wrapped like a mummy
anyway what i've recognized is enough is
also
it has to do with a particular time
frame so that palette of toilet paper is
enough toilet paper for two years maybe
sure i just don't want to purchase it
all at once yeah you don't want to
purchase it one square at a time you
don't want to purchase two years worth
right right so enough for what period
that's a great question
ryan now i want to hold up kathleen's uh
picture here she says
i want my house to look like this and
it's like the studio apartment maybe you
could describe it a bit i'll hold it up
for the youtube camera
well on just on one side of the room so
it's a big room and then it's divided
into a bath
bedroom a very tiny bedroom yeah very
tiny bedroom very tiny bathroom
kitchen dining lounge that's about
uh i would say ten percent yeah twenty
percent maybe yeah
uh and then the rest of it is just open
floor plan
and on the open floor plan it says
plants and that's it yeah i actually
know of someone who has done something
similar to this like
think about the mcmansions that there
there are in ohio
yes i know someone exists in florida and
yeah there's
so uh i was visiting a friend over a
couple weekends ago in las vegas and
they have friends who has this mcmansion
that they literally turned into like an
animal sanctuary
so it's like the way they were
describing it to me is
it the inside feels very outside like
they have a
big pond in their living room yes they
like rescue all these animals
it's very uh it's like a you know kind
of varnish
farmish i guess right but anyway um yeah
it's interesting because they have all
that space but like they did something
very similar to what
kathleen kathleen is doing with uh yeah
having very little living space and
mostly just space for
uh plants and animals so enough has a
lot to do with our
individual priorities right because if i
were to go live in kathleen space like i
have a few plants in my home you can
check out the home
tour over the minimalists.com resources
i believe
uh it's on our resource page ryan and i
both did home tours over there
anyway i have some plants but if we
filled my entire home
with plants it would drive me insane
yeah
in fact it's not even my my duty to
water the plants
uh that is beck's duty because it is her
desire to have the plants in the home in
the first place what are you doing she's
not there you just like
let him spit on
minerals right anyway kathleen has
enough for her
her idea of enough for her is too much
for me right and so keep that in mind as
well and all by the way
i might have too much of something for
her that is like more than enough
and more than enough is what most of us
have in most aspects of our life
yes and that's what we're gonna be
talking about today we got a question
from twitter uh barbara has a question
for us right
why does anyone want more getting to the
heart
of individual wise can be the key to
transformation
also the converse why does anyone want
to get rid of their stuff
the reasons are personal and figuring
those out can help one realize when they
are enough i think the the answer to the
first question ryan why does anyone want
more and the one word answer to that is
i think
it's fear and actually i don't think
that
the truth is that it's fear now what
type of fear is the question
because fear underlies any sort of
quote unquote negative emotion whether
that is
you know uh grief sadness whatever
there's attachment you know there's a
type of fear that is
we call desire right um now there are
various types of desire the more
pernicious kind we might call craving
and so if someone wants once more maybe
the better question here is
why do we always crave more
i think it has to do with like pleasure
which i think maybe we're saying the
same thing
yes um so yeah it's like you
you're scared of not feeling pleasure or
feeling happiness
so you run towards getting more because
the idea of that
makes you think that it's going to be
it's going to bring pleasure anthony
demelo says
that we aren't afraid of the unknown we
often hear
hear about the fear of the unknown he
said we're afraid of
losing the known yeah and the known
you're talking about here is that
dopamine rush that
pleasure and and so in a weird way we're
actually setting ourselves up for
displeasure
by searching for pleasure through all of
these ephemeral pursuits we all know
that it's not lasting if i get this and
i get that
i do feel the pleasure but the converse
of that is all of the peak is always the
valley you can't have
one without the other but of course and
there's nothing wrong with pleasure
but if we're always seeking pleasure we
won't have peace
and so i think in a weird way we
the to answer the second part of the
question here
she says why does anyone want to get rid
of their stuff
is because they recognize that they've
lost
peace in their life when you lose peace
you lose a particular kind of freedom
and so they're searching for freedom so
the fear
and the pleasure that drives the
consumption
ultimately for many of us leads to this
realization that
oh what i really crave isn't pleasure
it's peace it's freedom yeah i mean
there's got to be something primal there
too right
you know going back to like hunters
gatherers they
had to store up a bunch of food um think
about being you didn't know hunters and
guys
hunter-gatherers didn't store up food
um well i guess i'm thinking like
pre-industrial so like eighteen hundred
yeah agricultural societies did okay
sure yeah so um
and the reason why they did that though
is because
having to forage every time you needed
something to eat
uh was harder yeah it was harder it
wasn't as appealing as having like some
you know what do they call it uh cured
ham that's been sitting in salt
you know for all summer and you can just
go and get it so
i mean there is something there with and
it goes back to fear like the fear of
not having enough the fear of not having
sustenance so
since we have evolved to kind of have
this hoarding mentality
um it's just amplified by
post-industrial the post-industrial age
whether it's marketing convenience
convenience access to goods
um whether it's uh uh like
cheaply or easily made products you know
so
so mass production so yeah so it's like
that those things
feed into what is kind of naturally what
we've naturally evolved to
and it just it just really yeah
uh uh exponentially like increases our
desire to hoard
right and and now that desire is piqued
by other people's interests right
and marketers and advertisers they work
really hard to
increase your craving right and so as
before where you had a natural craving
oh i'm hungry that's a
natural desire to fulfill a basic human
need
to stay warm is a a natural desire to to
stay alive we're talking about things to
stay
alive and to ultimately reproduce
that's what we've evolved to do over
three hundred thousand or three million
years um
as as hominins um anyway
when i look at other sort of primate
ancestors
and we write about this and love people
use things oh hold that up for the
camera as well
we got a new book coming out in july
july 13th you can pre-order it right now
it helps us out a ton it's called love
people
use things love people use things.net
it's where you can find it but ryan and
i are even going to read it to you
yeah dude personally we're going to show
up in your living room
that's that's gonna be really annoying
it'll be like 2 a.m it's only if you buy
the vip package and there's only one
available
[Laughter]
no but in in the book what we talk about
is
they did the the study uh that i quote
in the book
of these primates bonobos and
chimpanzees our two
closest ancestors yeah right that are
still living
and and so when you look at it
they both behave the same when they're
babies or young
kids right when young bonobos young
chimps
see a horde of bananas yeah their first
inclination to share it with other
people
or other chimps and bonobos
hey bonobos are people too ryan
okay anyway
but as as they both get older they
bifurcate
and the the older
chimps will fight to the death to keep
their horde to keep their horde of
bananas they'll fight off all their
chimpanzees
isn't that or bonobos or people isn't
isn't there a piece of that study too
where it showed if a chimp had only one
banana or two bananas they would share
it
so if they had one they would eat it if
they had enough to share
um they would share if they had enough
to eat and share they would share it
with their group
if there was a horde of bananas they'd
fight for it
they would yeah fight like to the death
to maintain a horde which they could by
the way never eat all of those before
they go bad so this is exactly
what i'm trying to say like it's
ingrained in us
to have a horde man i mean i don't
it's a natural tendency where does it
come from i don't know sort of is
okay here's here's what i'm saying i
think we get to choose
we because oh of course we either get to
be as adults am i a bonobo
or am i a chimpanzee because the bonobos
continue to share
well into their adulthood and it's been
replicated over and over and over in
experiments and it's like
oh wow bonobos
that seems like what
that seems much more ideal than the the
violence the fear
yeah that causes the violence and that
causes hoarding
hoarding is caused by fear which is a
particular kind of
evil when you really think about it yeah
you know before we get into
some of our callers here ryan let me
read this excerpt
from love people use things this is
called
you don't need that ryan and i moved to
los angeles
in 2017 to establish a film and podcast
studio for the minimalists
as soon as we arrived in the city i
noticed i was drawn to what everyone
else
had already had granite countertops
teslas
limited edition air jordan sneakers
perhaps the american neoconceptual
artist jenny holzer
was on to something when she painted
quote the unattainable
is invariably attractive on the side
of a bmw art car at the porsche museum
in germany
think about that for a second ryan the
unattainable is attractive
when something is unattainable we seem
to want it more
and then as soon as we're able to attain
the thing we lose our desire
for it god there's something there too
with wanting what we can't
have exactly even as a minimalist i
found the overwhelming pool of
consumerism made it difficult
not to think i needed everything i saw
luckily i'd unknowingly been preparing
for the land of lamborghinis melrose
place and triple duck
triple decker strip malls for nearly a
decade if there is a core message within
minimalism
it's this you probably don't need that
think about that for a second minimalism
basically means you probably don't need
that
right if you sum it up in a pithy little
line
yeah minimalism you probably don't need
that we trick ourselves into believing
that
we do need that couch that cookware that
eyeliner that skirt that statuette
perhaps that's because we've evolved to
dupe ourselves the prime directive of
the mind is to deceive itself
claims the analytic philosopher bernardo
castro
author of more than allegory quote our
reality is created by an extraordinary
subtle process of self-deception
so we're constantly deceiving ourselves
and i think that goes into the
answering barbara's question here about
more why do we always want
more is because we're always deceiving
ourself
and the unattainable is attractive
and so we're attracted by these things
so we deceive ourselves that think we
need those things return to the text
here when you extend cash drops claim to
the material world
it instantly seems obvious if the
average household contains hundreds of
thousands of items
most of which get in the way and don't
increase our happiness
then why do we hold on to all that junk
the answer is simple because of the
stories we tell ourselves
that's why we hold on to junk and by the
way that's why we pursue more and more
and more
we tell ourselves these narratives that
we're not complete that we need
more yeah what disempowering stories do
you tell yourself
about your stuff what new empowering
stories could you
create to change that narrative i often
hear members of the media say that the
american dream is more out of reach than
ever
but that's not true it's easier than
ever to reach the american dream
the problem is we're reaching for the
wrong
things once upon a time the american
dream was
modest if you worked hard at your modest
job you could afford a
to build a modest house on a modest
piece of land and live a modest life
you would have enough
today however we want it all and we want
it now
a bigger house and a bigger car and a
bigger life
shopping sprees and lavish dinners and
instagram worthy moments because
we're addicted to the dopamine rush of
each new purchase it's never
enough to simply have enough
how much is enough without asking this
question we blindly pursue excess
we've been acculturated to drink from
the fire hose of consumption
acquire consume indulge more more more
how much is enough without an answer we
don't know how to proceed because
we don't know when to stop mindless
desire
takes us by the hand naturally enough
is different for each of us enough
changes as our needs and circumstances
change
your enough may include a sofa coffee
table and tv
a dining table that seats six a three
bedroom home a two car garage
a backyard trampoline or that might be
too much
enough changes over time yesterday's
enough maybe too much today
how much is enough less than enough is
depriving
more than enough is indulging
enough is the sweet spot in the middle
the place where intentionality
intersects with contentment
where lust doesn't get in the way of
creating something
meaningful sure you could pursue more
but could is not a good reason to do
anything
enough is enough when you decide
it's enough yeah so i love people use
things if you want to check out
the book comes out really soon in about
two months so
a lot of people use things.net or
pre-order it wherever you would get your
books
like your local indie bookshop emily has
a question for us in south carolina
i have a small business and work out of
my home and paper
is my enemy i unsubscribe from
everything
try to get off contact list and have
turned everything i can into
e-statements
however i still have the past seven
years of tax returns documents receipts
and other types of papers that i don't
know what to do with
i tried to go paperless last year for my
business but the app i was using would
mysteriously delete images
and spending and mileage that i had
spent time inputting
so i cancelled it because it made me
nervous
my question is how can i go paperless
for both my life and business
i get so worried that my computer will
crash or i'll have a fire or flood
but i also am not great with technology
and don't fully understand
backing things up or using the cloud and
things like that
so ryan when i hear emily here i
certainly identify with this although
i see some problems with her problem i
do
um what do you see well the first thing
i see is she said she's not adept with
using some of these things
and you know having enough
uh living a a minimalist lifestyle it's
there's
it's not easy yeah it's it's it's
difficult
and there are some things that you're
gonna uh
in her case there are some things you're
gonna have to maybe go out of your way
and learn how
to do right so um so that's that's my
way of saying
to uh emily here is don't be scared of
the technology
right embrace it yeah um you and i
didn't know how to do it until we knew
how to do it exactly like
go out of your way to a give yourself
permission
to kind of uh mess up a little bit and
have a little bit of a learning curve
i mean not to the extent of like
obviously we don't want her records
getting deleted
but uh but just don't be nervous going
into technology i don't know how else to
say it that's that's the first
the problem that i see is that she
sounds a little trepidatious to get into
the different apps and it's
understandable because it's overwhelming
and so i want to i want to break down
the problem make it a little bit
less overwhelming and in fact once we
identify what enough is you won't be
overwhelmed at all right now you're
overwhelmed because
you have more than enough information
now ryan and i are going to share some
practical tips with you we have some
articles i'll put a link to both of them
in the show notes
we'll get to those in a moment because
there are some practical things you can
do
however it's quixotic to think that i
can just do
i can add some apps and some technology
and
by adding more that's how i get down to
enough
yeah and that's why i thought this was
such a good question for this episode
because
we're not doing a full paper clutter
episode but it's worth at least
discussing now yeah
let's be clear ryan you and i aren't
paperless
we don't have a paper in fact here's
here's the ultimate irony here's this
new york times article we're going to
read from in a moment
or at least we'll put a link to in the
show notes it's called gear for a
paperless
off home office gear for a paperless
home office i've printed this out
on paper that's great now i do that for
the podcast for a reason let me
i don't just want to print things
willy-nilly but ryan and i have found
that
having screens between us actually
degrades the conversation
yeah and we're trying to avoid that and
so if i have to print out some paper
which by the way
is a renewable resource i've talked to
environmentalists
we've interviewed quite a few and
they're like well you know honestly
if you're if you're getting if you're
printing from using
your regrowth forests if you actually
care about trees
you use paper which seems
counterintuitive to me i'm not
completely on board with that yet
right i don't just like randomly use a
bunch of paper but for this podcast it
makes more sense than having
screens that create a barrier for us in
fact
i often think that our screens are are
creating all these new barriers
there's a lot of talk about building a
wall we've built walls and
and they're digital walls in between all
of us when you go out
you see it in memes all the time now
where it's like people are all
family around the dinner table and
they're all just like staring into this
this really enticing glowing box
i read a meme and said something like uh
i'll be watching uh netflix on the
internet
um and then i get bored so i have to see
what's going on on the little internet
yeah that's that's such a good point
it's like we don't watch tv anymore we
watch the internet
on the big internet or the small
internet right now we have medium
internet
the ronnie chang joke which is also in
love people use things in the technology
chapter
he says it seems like you know he's an
immigrant and he said it seems like
every night in america is a contest to
see how many screens i can get between
my face and the wall
yeah and he goes through the whole bit
and it's like the tv
and then i've got like my laptop and my
ipad and my iphone and then boom apple
watch
right oh my gosh yeah we have all these
screens in between us so
what i'm really saying here is if you
have a
problem that is not solvable
uh by technology i'm sorry that you
think is solvable by technology it may
be
solvable when you better understand the
problem it may be solvable without
technology
as well so let's help emily understand
let's do that so first off
uh becoming completely paperless is
sort is fine but if we're renouncing
paper
i'm never ever going to use paper again
what does that do
when you renounce something it forever
attaches you to it right
and so by renouncing paper what emily
has done inadvertently
and that's this is why it's so
overwhelming to her at first is she's
now attached herself to
not just paper but the idea that i must
be paperless
and therefore any bit of paper is an
indiscretion
and i have failed if i bring one post-it
note into my home office
yes so emily just consider yourself
paperless ish yeah paper full
paper i mean you are paper full right
now but here's the thing
what's the big problem if you've if
you've gone out of your way to be
relatively paperless or reduce the
amount of paper that you have maybe a
better way to put it
a paper reduction yeah if you have seven
years of tax records because your
accountant says
you need seven years of tax records okay
what's the problem with that if you have
the essential tax records i don't see a
problem with that
i have one file cabinet at home me too
that has some tax information has some
receipts in there
and then i'll go through there every 90
days and i call the
superfluous information out of there and
anything i don't need gets shredded and
then
boom i'm i'm done uh i don't have to
spend a ton of time on it
and i don't have to worry about it
because i know quarterly i just go
through there
extract the things and then also we have
a an accountant who actually handles
our business paperwork yeah and so
maybe that's an option i don't know if
you have an accountant but they may be
able to store the things for you
so our accountant actually stores our
tax information for us
which is really helpful and they store
it in the cloud it's all backed up and
it's secure
and you have to have someone and a
system that you trust
but it's okay to outsource some of that
trust as well yeah
the first thing that comes to mind for
me is like like a quickbooks type thing
where
it handles everything like you can put
taxes in there you can put receipts in
there
um and again emily this is gonna take
especially if you have
seven years worth of paper it's gonna
take some time to go paperless
right or uh to go paperless ish
to reduce your amount of paper but uh
yeah like so with our accountant um
yes like they handle everything but you
don't have to have an accountant
to handle everything you can have an
application that handles
we didn't have an account until a couple
years ago exactly and my feeling too she
was talking about things randomly
getting deleted
i mean there's i don't know what she was
using but there's probably
an easier solution than just giving up
well let's go into some of the solutions
here so
before we have a couple articles here in
fact i'm just going to put a link to
this one in the show notes
gear for a paperless home office this
has some different scanners and
different software etc
i'm not going to spend time reading
through the the entire article
but i will say that there are different
scanners and things out there that once
you
have understood the complexity of the
problem i'll say one other thing though
before ryan gets into his pc mag
article that he has here and we'll put a
link to that one in the show notes as
well
but let me just say this that if paper
is your enemy
then you might be fighting the wrong
battle right
right so i wouldn't treat paper as the
enemy and i i know you're saying that
tongue in cheek emily
but whenever i think of an enemy then
all of a sudden
i feel as though now i have something
that is insurmountable an
enemy it means i have to fight them i
have to battle them
well paper is just something i need to
scan i don't need to battle it right
and or shred it the truth is most of the
things that i'm holding on
to can probably be shredded without even
scanning it in the first that's what i
realized when i first embraced
minimalism
i was going through those scanning
parties i was like i was holding on to
so much stuff just in case
but then i just shredded it because i
never i knew i was never going to
actually
need it now you've got an article here
from pcmag what's it called
it is called five apps you need
to go paperless now what i like about
this ryan is it's not specific apps but
it's like a category of apps right
yes what's the first so the first one is
a to-do list
app so there are so many different
versions of this
um i use honestly i use my my notepad
i use apple notes yeah to do to do a
to-do list but there are apps out there
that will help you
color code and organize them a little
different i mean
you've got to decide what you're most
comfortable with evernote is one that i
a lot of people are familiar with sean
would you use something
that's google related right
there's some other there are some other
uh apps in this article as well what's
the
the second category second category is a
scanning app i also use apple notes for
that now
oh i didn't know you could do that yeah
so apple notes a few updates ago they
added the scanning capability so you can
scan things with your iphone and there's
a google equivalent if you have an
android smartphone
if you just have a flip phone like uh
the gal that i met over at the
oh oh someone just walked into our
studio here i think i just met a gal
over at the grocery store the other day
and she's like
hey minimalist like i i um delilah was
her name
uh she works at the grocery store she's
like i've been using a flip phone for
three months now
and she was showing them like that's
amazing so then you don't have the
scanning capability so
you and i also have like a photo scanner
document scanner that we've used in the
past before it was you were able to do
it with your phone
yeah that's another option as well yeah
super simple to use honestly like i use
i didn't know i could do that in notes
i'll start using that now but
i just i use my camera like if i need
something to take a picture of it and
then you can easily convert it to like a
pdf or something yeah that's what notes
does for you using your camera so yeah
that's great what's the next category
an e-signature tool this is pretty
valuable um i use docusign
yeah i was going to say like i think i'm
just thinking about all the things we've
had to sign over the years
and it seems like docusign is like
pretty much the easiest
technology to use yeah there are fewer
fewer places that are requiring what's
called a wet signature it's still a
thing which is
it's so odd it is yeah but if you don't
require a wet signature then
having the the doc you sign or the
equivalent there's no sponsorship here
you do whatever you want
yeah but that's that's just who we use
for sure and then there's a file syncing
service that's category number four
okay so file's thinking like dropbox is
what we use for example
uh google has uh their their version of
this as well
box is another company that does the the
so
basically let me explain if my computer
were to crash
or my home were to burn down my entire
apartment building burned down
everything that's on my hard drive would
be destroyed
but it's also backed up onto dropbox and
it automatically syncs dropbox is
relatively simple for me
and we pay an annual fee in order to
make that you know work because you're
you're it's you're paying for storage
space basically 100
i know emily said she wasn't comfortable
with the cloud but again this is one of
those things emily if
if you're not willing to embrace the
technology then
you are going to be stuck with a bunch
of paper right and so and that's okay
that's the cost of admission
of course and so the there are a couple
options here ryan you can have
in fact i have redundancy and so it's
much safer than if i were just have a
bunch of paperwork in my
attic which i don't have an addict but
it was in my closet and the place burned
down paperwork's gone and
there's nothing i can do about it
there's no way i can it's not backed up
anywhere
now if i have it on my hard drive and
then the paperwork's shredded
and then my hard drive is destroyed then
all the same thing as if my house caught
on fire
now if it's on the hard drive and it's
in the cloud now i have some redundancy
yeah so even if something were to happen
to my computer or if something were
happening in the cloud
i have backup options here 100 and
what's the fifth category right fifth
category
is a document sharing tool
so document sharing tool like what what
are the examples they provide oh
um a common way to send digital
documents is attach them to an email
that option isn't always ideal
however because you can't always tell
when or if the recipient got them
like google drive sort of thing yeah you
can use red receipts but they only work
if the recipient hasn't blocked or
declined them
okay all right well we'll put a link to
that in the show notes and enjoy those
five different they say five apps right
but really it's just five categories to
help you go paperless or
maybe a better way to say it is paper
light if we go paper light
in which ryan and i are even though
during our podcast it's by far the most
paper heavy part of our week in fact i
i can't think of any time i print
anything else except during
our podcast so i can avoid having any
screen in this room whatsoever
yeah and it is calming strangely right
but
by removing those screens i feel like
it's it's just me and you in this room
and
shawn and jordan who are naked it's
really strange i don't know why they do
this
naked minimalist ryan what time is it
you know what time it is it's time for
the lightning round where we answer your
text messages you can text your
questions and comments to 937-202-4654
yes indeed now during the lightning
round this is where ryan
do our best to answer questions of the
short shareable less than 140 character
response
we put the text to those minimal
maximums in the show notes so you can
copy and share our pithy answers on
social media if you'd like
you can find all of our minimal maxims
in one place now it's called
minimalmaxims.com we got a question ryan
yeah from carol how do we learn to
recognize the difference between enough
and a false sense of security and
comfort from
unnecessary consumerism well here's my
pithy answer which i already read to you
from love people use things is how i
ended that passage
enough is enough when you decide it's
enough yeah now let's unpack
that so getting back to her question
here how do we learn to recognize
well learning and recognizing are two
different things so maybe we'll just say
how do we recognize
recognize as a type of understanding i
would even call a low-grade
understanding
so how do we understand enough
is really what her question is like how
and
that becomes not an intellectual
exercise that becomes a visceral
exercise when you talk about the
palettes of toilet paper it's not that
there is a number
that you can understand i i've
understood that
17 rolls of toilet paper is the right
amount for me to purchase
no no it's a feeling and and and that's
really where the truth lies i'm not
talking about the fact here i'm talking
about the truth the truth
is that i'm going to buy enough for me
yeah and that might not be enough for
you but of course enough is enough when
you've decided
or maybe even better put enough is
enough when you understand
it's enough yeah yeah i uh
my pithy answer is this don't confuse
enough with perfection or don't confuse
enough
for perfection and the thing is is
there's not a number for enough right
there's not
um enough is not an exact it is a
i look at it as a uh
you know there's there's a range of what
enough is and to me it's
it's a the essence of yeah of of being
of having the appropriate amount of
things yeah so
if you confuse enough with perfection
then you're never gonna feel like you
have enough or you
you're always gonna feel like either you
have too little or too much right
um it's like saying did i drink enough
water today now of course they
certain people recommend 64 ounces of
water eight eight glasses of water a day
right but of course well that's
confusing as well because
there are different qualities of water a
moment ago we talked some water
you go to flint you drink 64 ounces of
lead water
that's actually bad for you that's more
than
enough because it's detrimental to you
anything that is detrimental to
you is more than enough yeah
and so it has to do with the quality of
enough
as well the quality of that water does
it have the appropriate minerals and
and and even then it's not the 64. even
if you have
the perfectly filtered water from
mountain valley arkansas
yeah it it has the minerals but
is 64 ounces the perfect number and
therefore
everything else is imperfect everything
else is more than enough or not enough
no it's not that it depends on all kinds
of other factors did i work out today
am i sweating more what environment
what's my altitude
enough is a feeling just as much more so
than it is
a quantity yeah it's it's perspectival
and it you know it's up to each
individual to kind of
really accept what's appropriate i would
i would stop looking at enough
and start looking at appropriate if if i
was having an issue with
you know understanding like oh do i have
enough the question i would start asking
myself is what's the appropriate
amount of whatever it is that i'm
looking for and you can back into enough
because
ooh here's another pithy one for you
sean enough is always
appropriate um yes
boom all right ryan we got a bunch more
to talk about but first what do you got
for us
here are some voicemail comments and
insights from our listeners
check them out hey josh and ryan this is
jansen from memphis
you may already know about this but you
can make bananas
taste like ice cream if you freeze them
and then blend them in a food processor
you can add peanut butter or honey or
other fruit to it or whatever
hi josh and ryan this is theresa from
minneapolis minnesota calling in regards
to the digital clutter episode
i've actually been carrying down a lot
of social media recently going through
each removing old posts and accounts
and this has been tedious but it's also
been a good reminder of all the time
i've wasted
currently i'm going through facebook and
i wasn't planning to because i'm a
nostalgic person but it's been
eye-opening
seeing all these old posts of times that
there was a lot of not so great memories
or times that i had posted
having a great time but i was actually
going through a hard time in my life
it's actually made it easier for me to
let go of these posts now now that i've
seen
that it wasn't as great as i remembered
so that's helped me move forward with
that
one other tip for using social media on
your computer is to bookmark a different
page
of that site instead of the main page so
for youtube i have it linked to my
subscription page
facebook is linked to a custom friends
list i made of just close
friends and family that way i'm only
looking at a short condensed page when
i'm logging in
and most days i'm only spending about
one or two minutes
on facebook and youtube just seeing
what's in there and then closing it and
being done for the day
so hopefully someone will find these
helpful and thanks and have a great day
all right joe we have a bunch more
surprise questions this thursday on
patreon that's the maximal
episode on the minimalist private
podcast themminimalists.com
support if you want to subscribe but
first real quick for right here right
now here's one thing that's going on in
the life of the minimalists
we want to help you find enough
i'm going to help you declutter your
smartphone and computer as well
uh the minimalists have seven different
wallpapers you can download all seven
for free for your smartphone or computer
that's the love people use things
wallpaper which you get for free
scrolling is the new smoking what a
timely reminder right now
less is now which we actually had before
our film came out
yeah it was it was really a mantra for
us like you know obviously
the the less is more the the the old
saying by uh
van mise um or van der rohe rather mies
van der rohe
uh he he he coined less is
more and we said well yeah but less is
now
and so so now is the important part of
that
and then of course what i really want to
get across to you
five questions to ask before buying this
is great
and so i love that list when we're
struggling with enough
what is it ryan it's like i i go into a
store and it's like well i
i want this i want that i want that it's
fear-based we just talked about that
yeah but this is a little reminder it's
right there on the home screen of your
phone
download it for free yeah i don't know
why i didn't think about this earlier in
the episode but like that
is a great tool to help you help you uh
understand what enough is right yeah
right because
question this question always helps us
identify what is too much what is too
little
and what is enough you can download
those for free right now over on our
resources page
the minimalists.com slash resources for
our added value this week ryan
i want to play you a new song it's
called perfume it's a
on this ep called sky on fire the guy's
name is marrow not like jesus and maro
it's this young kid and the video for
this
is a great video but these lyrics really
stood out to me because
we're always sort of yearning for
more than enough and the the sort of
opening lines to the song here is the
present is so
unsatisfying i wish i was materialistic
excited for the future unfolding thank
god i'm not realistic
and he goes on to this line says i'd be
a fool not to love you
now there's this song and it's a
gorgeous song which you're going to hear
in a moment
but think about that thank god i'm not
realistic
i wish i was more materialistic so
i'm not materialistic and therefore i'm
not realistic therefore realistic
in our society is to be materialistic
and so when we are being realistic
you hear those people say this all the
time i can be a minimalist that's just
not realistic
yeah yeah that's the point it's a whole
yeah
the point is we're trying to not be
realistic anymore how is realistic
working out for you
enjoy the song it's really beautiful
marrow's song it's called
perfume we have a bunch more surprise
questions
this week like how do we find the
strength to oppose the status quo how do
we teach our children to be happy
with what they have and not compare
their belongings
with the belongings of others how do you
handle when you're enough is different
from your partners
enough i'm sure ryan has some insight on
that plus the science behind why our
brains miss
opportunities to improve through
subtraction
and a million more questions for the
minimalist if you want to hear all that
join us on the minimalist private
podcast this week
visit the minimalists.com support to
subscribe and get your personal link
so that our private podcast plays in
your favorite podcast
app by the way now is the time to
subscribe you can join thousands of
other folks because
we're building a brand new studio you
see we're in this temporary studio space
right now if you're watching the video
version
but now is the time because you're going
to help us build the studio and it is
going to be
beautiful we have some wonderful plans
plus you get all of our archives talk
about enough
there's enough to listen to for a very
long time we have a palette
of private podcast episodes out there
and you can
you can actually just dive in though you
don't have to take home the whole
palette you just go in there and grab
one roll at a time
digitally whenever you'd like and you
wipe your butt with our minimalism
you can follow the minimalist on
facebook twitter and instagram at the
minimalist
come to one of our live podcast shows
visit theminimalists.com
tour to find a city near you if you have
a question comment or minimalism tip
email a voice memo to podcast
minimalists.com
you can comment on this episode
youtube.com slash the minimalist if you
want our show notes in your inbox sign
up for our email list over at the
minimalists.com you'll also receive our
simple sunday
emails any minimalist writings that we
write you'll get those
for free right there in your inbox and
if you leave here today with just one
message
we hope it's this love people and use
things because the opposite
never works thanks for listening y'all
we'll see you next time
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet
that you'll be fine without it